Cory did a lot of people think that
Tessa would not need to tap the capital
markets to fund the ramp up here well
Tesla for a long time said they weren't
going to and then they changed course
and said they were going to the last
conference call Elon Musk warned they
were to look at the public market
without a debt or equity this is a big
equity deal and a big dilution for
current shareholders but that's the only
way they can get these cars built I mean
they've announced some very ambitious
plans about building this model 3 but
they don't have the capacity to build it
they're gonna have to spend billions of
dollars to build out another factory
they don't have the batteries or the
ability to build that many batteries so
this is a costly effort of course Tessa
loses money in every single car that
they make and so this is a problem to
put it mildly they're hoping they can
somehow make a 35 thousand dollar car
that's profitable when they're
hundred-thousand-dollar car isn't that's
going to take a lot of money from Wall
Street to get them in that direction
Cory we're seeing the market sell-off a
little bit on this news but was this
basically expected that people know they
were going to have to come back into the
equity market to raise more cash for
their further adventures I think I think
that I think that it looked like the
preferred way to do this was going to be
equity because it's been such popularity
around the stock and furthermore the two
billion dollar number seemed like it was
going to be rightly that's what I was
kind of expecting when I try to figure
out what this is going to cost but you
know who knows with this company I mean
it's hard to imagine these cars gonna be
profitable or what the feature set is
going to be there's a lot of speculation
on Wall Street and guesses all over the
map but how many of the deposits will be
realized there's the story out there in
yahoo news awhile back about someone
who'd made ten deposits on the model
threes hoping that the car would be very
popular be able to resell them at a
profit when the cars ship so you know
there's a lot of different analyst
estimates about how many orders will
ultimately be cancelled what the true
demand for the car would be there
looking at the Model X and some people
are saying as many as half of those
orders got pulled and customers one of
their money back so it's hard to predict
what the demand is going to be for this
car Tesla's got to figure all that out
build the factor to manage that kind of
production and try to sell that car so
it's a great struggle for them this will
give them the cash to start to get there